cinquième jour consécutif de grève à la
sncf les négociations sont dans
l'impasse et fo et la cgt manifestaient
aujourd'hui contre la réforme de la
sécurité sociale
invité du journal le ministre des
transports monsieur bernard qui a servi
à l'om bernard tapie condamné à huit
mois de prison ferme ce pourvoi en
cassation jacques mellick condamné à un
an de prison avec sursis un policier
suisse avait sauvé plusieurs centaines
de juifs fuyant l'allemagne sanctionné
il est enfin réhabilité à titre posthume
50 en plus en angleterre une cassette
vidéo tout à fait spéciale une
compilation des images saisies par les
caméras de surveillance images
inattendues violentes y passe voilà
monsieur bonsoir
avant de faire le point sur les
négociations en cours à la sncf et le
bilan de la journée d'action de force
ouvrière et de la cgt
la france a vécu une cinquième journée
consécutive de grève d'attentes
interminables dans les gares la tension
est montée d'un cran
embouteillage monstre également autour
des grandes villes et principalement à
paris
25 à 30 km de bouchons ce matin autour
de la capitale et ce soir une
circulation toujours très dense richard
fenwick vous êtes dans votre hélicoptère
au dessus des principaux axes routiers
autour de paris bonsoir je vais
parfaitement à paris après dix minutes
mais ça devient quitter la porte de
sortie
on n'a pas tout de bagnolet et à face à
face de la chapelle dans de champerret
baggaley salaire est un parking total à
86 de rosny vers le pont de nogent est
arrivé pour les cultures nationales 186
à 86 ans reçu le ciel gemalto rousselet
c'est très très très dur de l'ouest
vient dick cheney a beaucoup s'en est
presque au ralenti mais après microsoft
améliore encore cours on est plutôt
nation à 907 par votre sur laquelle
mobilise de vie la mère d'accueil
pénible et la n104 de ma chaîne est à
l'étude et à liart et bloquer les a
beaucoup de gens se soient ont pris les
personal unocal et roanne n'est pas
forcément le meilleur creusot se laisse
complètement tranquille jusqu'au pont de
nogent la haca de gennevilliers vers sa
noire
mon père a alors dû nord de la porte de
la chapelle vers la courneuve est
également très inventive et les messages
de paris être humain la vue mais si
richard pour ses renseignements après
les embouteillages vue du ciel donc
comme vous les avez vus à l'instant les
voici maintenant au niveau de la route
et de la rue à paris une véritable
journée de chiens faute sans père
christian hottin paris la porte maillot
il ya une demi heure pour dégager la
banlieue et puis maintenant bon gars
on est sa durée
sa part bull
dans un sens comme dans l'eau des
périphériques surchargé et au dessus des
dizaines de piétons un peu fatigué
si vous pensez de tout ça on l'a déjà
monsieur je vais tellement et agressif
que ça passera pas à la télé d'un côté
juste pour eux de l'autre ça fait chier
vu la grande pagaille 16 heures des
milliers de personnes quittent leur
travail plus tôt et même les feux ici
presse de clichy y perdent leur latin
vélo stocks
tout est bon
je fais du stop savoir si quelqu'un peux
m'avancer jusqu'à la douzième et puis
bah je trouve que les gens sont pas du
tout solidaire et vous regarde comme ça
qu'on est bien allé un sourire un peu
d'espoir et ça marche
dans le métro
aujourd'hui niveau des pieds ça c'est
horrible on peut marcher tellement qu'on
en a marre quoi ras-le-bol ras-le-bol à
18 heures plus grand chose à faire à
moins d'être un roi du patin à roulettes
courage demain est un autre jour est
maintenant très peu ou pas du tout de
train aujourd'hui dans toute la france
les candidats au voyage sont retrouvés
dans des conditions qui relève de l'
aventure des plus hasardeuses la colère
des voyageurs commencent à monter
sérieusement sébastien guibert ce tgv
est une rareté
c'est le seul à avoir quitté dit
d'aujourd'hui prévu à 8h il est
finalement parti à 11 heures et il n'y
en aura pas d'autres demain les gares de
la région était déserte pas les rails
dit loi les cheminots grévistes ont
bruyamment manifesté leur point de vue
et en ce moment mieux vaut se rendre à
londres qu'à calais et saint-omer
l'eurostar circulent parfaitement il y
avait parfois de quoi se prendre la tête
dans les gares de la région lyonnaise
à peine quelques tgv en provenance et à
destination de paris
pas de trains régionaux des quais
déserts et pour cause
la grande majorité des cheminots plus de
2000 a manifesté à lyon constituant
l'essentiel du cortège les manifestants
s'en sont pris surtout le premier
ministre
à marseille en gare saint-charles la
situation al'avantage d'être clair et
net
j'attends le train pour rentrer sur
montbéliard puis quand même temps ça
fait cinq jours que j'attends
monsieur risque d'attendre encore toute
la journée de mercredi
trafic nul en perspective et pour jeudi
c'est l'inconnue des infirmières au
chevet d'une sécurité sociale mal en
point voient là un symbole que les
cheminots en grève ont sûrement apprécié
hormis de défiler entre sept et quinze
mille manifestants la journée a surtout
été marquée par un trafic ferroviaire
complètement bloqué les autres services
publics et les bus ou fonctionner
correctement
demain devra être si difficile aucun
train n'est prévu dans la région pour
faire oublier que le trafic était bloqué
aujourd'hui à rennes
les cheminots grévistes ont mené une
opération de charme expliquer au grand
public leurs motivations et faire signer
une pétition
certains usagers sont convaincus
rage que les gens soient tringle ennuis
ils sont deux ils se moquent de nous ils
font du chantage tout avant rien
ils ont besoin ya là un moyen que les
grévistes utiliseront encore demain
après ce tour d'horizon à un exemple une
de nos équipes s'est embarqué ce matin à
bord d'un tgv paris lyon qui en temps
normal mais deux heures pour joindre les
deux villes vincent nguyen philippe
gantois si ce monsieur rentre chez lui à
annecy son train est bloqué à une
centaine de kilomètres de paris mais il
dort il dort parce que sa journée a
commencé très tôt et bien mal comme les
autres voyageurs ce matin en gare de
lyon ils étaient un peu perdus pas un
guichet ouvert pas d'informations ou si
peu il semblerait qu'ils aient un train
vers 10 heures mais je sais vraiment pas
du tout ce que j'ai vécu je continue à
chercher ou 20 billets voir si un frère
s'il faut pas de billets premier train
qui va lyon rentre dedans puis j'irai
bien
reste à attendre que la sncf fiche la
voie sur laquelle se trouve ce premier
train 21h50 pas d'affichage mais une
rumeur tout le monde ferait parler parce
qu'elle est par là c'est le contre et il
ya de la place pour tout le monde qu'on
est payés ou pas 10h30
une demi heure de retard et le train
démarre mais pour s'immobiliser un peu
plus loin quelques minutes mais à
plusieurs reprises au début je me suis
demandée par partir à paris mesure de
sécurité entre ces petits arrêts la
vitesse est limitée
aujourd'hui le tgv s'est laissé doubler
par les voitures puis à midi vers sens
la présence de manifestants
vi sur la voie verte tour obligé à
stopper et seront retenus pour une durée
déterminée
un retard supplémentaire de 40 minutes
dont notre dormeur ne s'apercevra au
raizet à son arrivée à lyon perrache le
tgv hu a mis cinq heures au lieu de 2 au
lieu d'arriver à 10h45 à 15h30 presque
chauve comme ça à lyon il est des jours
où décidément rien ne marche au
cinquième jour de la grève de la sncf et
des transports en commun de la ratp dans
une ville comme paris
les salariés commencent à ressentir
réellement les effets des arrêts de
travail
exemple dans une compagnie d'assurance
du centre de la capitale dans cette
entreprise
les employés doivent pointer chaque
matin maryse burgot finit plus de grève
ou pas danser ceux ci étaient privés on
pointe matin et soir
entré chez vous oui
ça fait comme 23 stations métro la
rocqué quoi ça va faire trois heures de
marche
alors cet après-midi la pointeuse à
fonctionner dès 15h30
les salariés de cette société
d'assurance était très pressé de partir
la route allait être longue parce qu'ils
ont ce matin on a mis quatre heures et
demie est rentré de bonheur d'enfants
récupérer résultats à 16 heures des
bureaux déserts ou presque les tout
derniers salariés sont sur le départ
en ces jours de grève la direction est
un peu obligés d'oublier sa pointeuse
ils viennent et à partir de ce moment là
ils n'auront pas d'heures
supplémentaires à récupérer même s'ils
ne font que quatre ou cinq heures de
travail simplement effective dans la
journée oui je lui dis que c'est
claudine à on se prépare aux baissiers
en part d'accord mais elles devront
marcher plus d'une heure pour rejoindre
leurs banlieues alors elles ont décidé
de faire la route ensemble et à
plusieurs
l'ambiance est plutôt détendue et demain
elles auront droit à la même promenade
forcé en fin de journée pour l'ambiance
entre collègues la grève a quand même
quelques bons côtés
la grève de la sncf s'ajoutaient
aujourd'hui la journée de mobilisation
de force ouvrière aider à l'occasion par
la cgt à grand défilé était organisé à
paris qui a réuni entre trente mille
personnes selon la police et 65 mille
selon ses organisateurs agnès molinier
franck brisset
poignée de mains très attendu entre les
frères ennemis du syndicalisme les deux
organisations n'ont jamais défilé
ensemble depuis 1947 date de leurs
scissions force ouvrière avait décidé de
défiler aujourd'hui seuls mais au
dernier moment la cgt fait rallier sont
pas venus prêter main forte
si on n'avait pas un objectif qui était
similaire il serait pas là c'est tout
nous sommes ensemble aujourd'hui dans la
rue dans les arrêts de travail pour des
femmes de sécurité sociale c'est ce qui
me paraît le plus important
pas de querelles de chapelles en tout
cas chez les cheminots qui soit fo cgt
ou même si fdt aujourd'hui les annonces
d'un même pas de faire reculer ce plan
sur la sécurité sociale et moi
personnellement ce cheminot des
sculpteurs nous fait payer de tous les
bords et y en a c'est resté aujourd'hui
pour deux raisons principales contre le
plan juppé quand c'est la protection
sociale et surtout contre le contrat
plan même si force ouvrière a vraiment
fait le plein de ses troupes aujourd'hui
à paris elle n'a pas mobilisé
seuls les renforts de jo signant de
l'infection mais surtout de la cgt ne
passait pas inaperçu
face au dollar dans ce voyeur ont sur ce
cas tous les salariés c'est tout à fait
différent
à partir du moment les gens sont
mécontents mais ont fait voir notre
mécontentement tous ensemble et c'est
logique
les syndicats ne prévoit pas pour
l'instant de nouvelles démonstrations de
force sur les pavés parisiens mais le
climat social reste tendu
dès jeudi les étudiants descendent à
nouveau dans la rue manifestation donc à
paris et d'autres défilés ont eu lieu en
province comme ici ce matin marseille ou
vingt mille personnes ont défilé
manifestations également à toulouse et à
lyon
les syndicats cgt cfdt fo et autonome de
la ratp annonce une reconduction de leur
mouvement de grève pour demain attention
donc pour les parisiens et les habitants
l'île de france mais c'est à la sncf que
l'on s'attend à une nouvelle journée
encore pratiquement 100 trains les
cheminots conteste à la fois la mise en
cause de leur régime de retraite et le
contrat de plan que leur entreprise doit
passer avec l'état pour réduire son
endettement considérable et malgré
toutes les avances faites aujourd'hui du
côté du gouvernement une majorité de
cheminots sont sur une ligne du
reportage dans un important centre de la
sncf
c'est au mans jacques cardoze nathalie
gallet depuis hier 13 heures plus aucun
train ne circule et pour cause il occupe
un point stratégique le poste de
régulation à commande informatisée 200
cheminots sont réunis ici autour des
mêmes revendications
le régime des retraites mais aussi
l'incertitude de l'emploi vient le
contrat de plan sncf qui prévoit la
suppression de 6000 kilomètres de lignes
régionales le ballon sur la sarthe aux
risques pour l'emploi nouveau la sncf
puisque l'atelier il ya 500 emplois -
aucune assurance sur l'avenir la charge
de travail au lieu de trois ans à venir
aussi l'action aujourd'hui est
clairement aussi vers les usagers pour
la sncf c'est la défense service public
puisque je d'importants éléments du
territoire je pense qu'on met en avant
quant à l'annoncé faite aujourd'hui par
le gouvernement concernant l'effacement
d'une partie de la dette
elle ne satisfait pas ces grévistes
l'état s'est pourtant engagé à reprendre
en deux tranches 37 milliards de francs
sur 175 milliards de la dette globale
par la suite toute amélioration du
résultat d'exploitation sera accompagnée
d'un allègement par l'état sur les
charges financières de la snc 25
milliards pour l'année 96 et après on va
demander aux cheminots de faire
l'économie sur les emplois sur les
salaires d'un milliard pour toucher 1
milliard on répartit du gouvernement
vous trouvez que c'est un accord normal
ça nous on est la sncf
on n'est pas des temps nos droits nos
valeurs on est un service public on
tient à rester service public ce soir
des groupes de manifestants ont défilé
dans les rues du mans pour certains
syndicalistes
il ne s'agit pas d'un coup de colère
passager mais bien d'une action au long
j'ai pas question de toucher au statut
en signe de colère
ils sont même allés jusqu'à mur et la
permanence du rpr de la salle le
gouvernement a donc annoncé aujourd'hui
qu'il augmentait de 12 milliards 37
milliards au total son aide au
remboursement de la dette de la sncf
contre un effort de productivité
donnant-donnant chantage ont répondu les
syndicats le gouvernement a ajouté qu'il
n'entendait pas remettre en cause de
régimes de retraite spécifique des
cheminots et ce soir la négociation a
repris pascal golomer jacques dernier
attention une table ronde peut en cacher
une n'a pas d'être allé hier chez
jacques barrot les syndicats de
cheminots on retrouve ce soir leur
président jean bergougnoux cette fois
pour parler en détails du contrat de
plan pour le sait depuis ce matin l'état
reprendra l'année prochaine 37 des 175
milliards de francs de dettes que la
sncf sans contrepartie pour le reste
tout dépendra des résultats de
l'entreprise et donc des efforts des
cheminots en matière salariale notamment
si le résultat s'améliore la dette sera
allégée ce sera francs pour franck
donnant-donnant chantage dénoncé
syndicats le donnant donnant et fossés
et d'entrer dans la mesure où c'est la
dette de l'état que l on se supporte
sépare la veine des cheminots n'est ni
des usagers
c'est l'actionnaire unique et étape qui
n'a pas participé à ces investissements
dans le mode ferroviaire c'est donc à
lui de trouver les moyens pour assumer
ses responsabilités mais après coup ce
plan que rejette la cgt et la cfdt c'est
pour jean bergougnoux le plan de la
dernière chance
encore faut-il convaincre des cheminots
lancer dans le conflit le plus dur
depuis 1986 pascal golomer en direct de
l'endroit où se passent les négociations
quel est le climat en ce moment pascal
que l'on n'imagine mal ici une fan
conflit rapide dans les toutes
prochaines heures
un conflit difficile en fait puisqu'il
porte sur deux dossiers bien distincts
le contrat de plan on vient de le voir
et puis le régime des retraites un
régime particulier auquel sont très
attachés les cheminots mais que le
gouvernement voudrait réformer ou en
tous les cas mettre à plat c'est le
terme officiel est en fait c'est de là
que pourrait peut-être venu à
l'ouverture parce qu'on sait que les
conducteurs sont très mobilisés sur ce
thème et ce sont eux qui aujourd'hui
bloque le trafic ferroviaire alors s'il
pouvait avoir quelques garanties quant
au maintien de leur régime
s'il pouvait y avoir un signe en ce sens
de la part de le goût du gouvernement il
est fort possible que l'add-on évolue
rapidement
merci pascal on va poser la question
directement à monsieur bernard pons le
ministre des transports monsieur pons
bonsoir bonsoir monsieur pons vous avez
entendu la question par notre
journaliste interposés est ce que vous
pouvez garantir ce soir clairement qu'on
touchera pas au système de retraite des
cheminots
mais il n'a jamais été question de
toucher au système de retraite des
cheminots
il ya un problème sur les traite tout le
monde le sait depuis longtemps le
gouvernement ait décidé de faire un
effort en la matière pour améliorer la
situation
il y à des régimes spéciaux de retraite
et en particulier les cheminots d'un
régime spécial
il n'a jamais été question de remettre
en cause ce régime spécial
alors je vais préciser en ministre va
installer deux mains une commission qui
est chargée de regarder les problèmes de
ces régimes spéciaux de façon à les
consolider et à assurer leur avenir
alors j'ai causé remis la question
encore un peu plus précisément par
exemple pour le personnel roulant comme
on dit à la sncf est ce que la retraite
reste très bien à 50 ans restera bien 50
ans mais il n'a jamais été question de
remettre en cause l'âge de départ à la
retraite
la commission examinera l'ensemble des
régimes spéciaux et veron et verra les
différentes propositions qu'il faut
faire pour assurer la
ni té et l'avenir de ces régimes
spéciaux qui aujourd'hui sont menacés
oui donc je crois qu'à l'heure actuelle
on joue à se faire peur bien cela dit
monsieur pons vous n'avez pas répondu
précisément est ce que vous pensez pas
que tout cela ces réponses participa à
l'amalgamé à la mauvaise entente entre
en ce moment entre sein des classes hier
et d'eric si on vous dit il n'est pas
question de toucher au régime spécial de
retraite des cheminots bien alors pour
ce qui concerne la sncf alors à votre
avis pourquoi est ce que on n'avance pas
ce soir pour espérer ce qu'on en est là
cinq jours de grève mais je crois que on
n'avance pas parce que depuis quelques
jours de les les fausses informations
circulent on joue à se faire peur
on annonce la suppression de 6000
kilomètres de lignes de chemin de fer
dans le contrat de plan il n'en est
jamais question
on dit que l'apport de l'état est
insuffisant 37 milliards sans
contrepartie immédiatement et ensuite on
propose que pendant cinq ans je rappelle
quand même que ces 37 7 milliards vont
permettre d'éponger les déficits qui se
sont cumulées entre 1990 et 1995
donc c'est un effort sans précédent de
l'état et ce qui est sans précédent
c'est que contrairement à ce qui avait
été fait en 1990 où l'état avait donné
38 milliards puis plus rien là l'état
propose de passer un véritable contrat
et il dit a la sncf les cheminots
si vous faites des efforts et nous
savons que vous pouvez faire des efforts
et nous savons que vous allez réussir à
faire des efforts
l'état donnera la même contrepartie jeu
c'est à dire que si vite vous diminuer
le déficit d'un franc l'état donnera
astres en supplément j'ai bien
l'impression monsieur minsk c'est là que
le bât blesse mais on va en parler dans
un sens jours et vous montrez un
reportage cet après midi à l'assemblée
nationale l'opposition se faisait l'écho
des revendications des syndicats et la
majorité unanime rpr udf tenez bon sur
la ligne juppé il faut que les réformes
passent il n'ya pas d'autre choix roland
sicard
françois garnier
le mardi à l'assemblée les coureurs sont
souvent embouteillées mais c'est normal
c'est le jour où le gouvernement vient
s'expliquer et aujourd'hui les députés
attendait des précisions sur le combat
social les facs la sécu les retraites la
sncf
il aurait été mis en entendre alain
juppé mais ce sont ces ministres qui ont
parlé avec un message simple le dialogue
il est toujours permanent mais la ferme
tu es sera toujours au rendez-vous quand
il s'agit de l'avenir du pays via log et
fermeté voilà donc les limonier constat
dans la majorité
cette ligne-là fait recette on est dans
une situation qui exige des solutions
parfois draconiennes et dur voire même
insupportable il faut cependant les
prendre il faut que le gouvernement
fasse preuve d'une très grande
compréhension mais qu'il ne lâche pas
sur l'essentiel soutien à droite c'était
le premier constat le deuxième c'est
qu'à gauche l'opposition tire le signal
d'alarmé et vise le gouvernement qui
choisit pendre le pourrissement passage
en force où le dialogue ils essaient de
mais la jeune cocktail qui est à mon
avis dangereux parce que tu sais pas
très bien ce qu'il fait et ne suffit pas
de donner quelques milliards la sncf si
on persiste dans la volonté d'aller vers
ce contrat de plan particulièrement
pernicieux et dangereux pour l'avenir du
service public de la grande entreprise
qu'est la caserne
une opposition qui s'oppose mais une
droite qui tient bon pour le
gouvernement c'est l'essentiel
car à l'assemblée c'est la règle quand
la majorité avance en rangs serrés
inutile de passer en force alors
monsieur pons questions politiques
comment allez vous sortir de toutes ces
affaires on a parlé de la sncf mais
aussi la réforme de la sécurité sociale
et je n'ai pas encore parlé des
universités vous savez nous sommes en
démocratie
je comprends parfaitement qui est un
certain nombre de manifestations
il faut savoir si un gouvernement c'est
fait pour laisser pourrir les choses si
c'était pour laisser pourrir les choses
et bien on voit le résultat
parce que les gouvernements successifs
ont laissé pourrir les choses et on voit
la dégradation de la situation
la dette de la france la situation des
régimes sociaux le gouvernement est tout
à fait décidée à redresser les choses et
je prends que les français en sont
parfaitement conscients
monsieur et je pense que au delà de
cette agitation le bon sens et la
responsabilité prendront dessus et je
pense que les cheminots à qui on demande
des efforts comme à tous les français
verront que les contribuables sont aussi
des efforts et que l'écran contribuables
ce sont aussi les usagers de la sncf
monsieur le ministre gros merci ajoute
encore que madame nicole notât continue
de jouer les différences au nom de la
cfdt aujourd'hui à maubeuge avait
déclaré il ya peut-être un espoir dans
ce pays pour un syndicalisme qui ne
disent pas seulement non qui ne veut pas
simplement que les choses ne bougent pas
et qui de fêtes organise la régression
sociale
cinq jours de grève à la sncf ce n'est
pas suffisant pour évidemment
désorganiser l'ensemble de l'économie
française mais des entreprises qui
traitent directement avec les chemins de
fer connaissent déjà des problèmes
plance duprat à lens
tous les transporteurs routiers ne
profite pas de la grève de la sncf
bien au contraire les spécialistes du
transport combiné rail route sont les
premiers pénalisés quand les trains ne
roulent plus les containers restent à
quai lorsque nous faisons aux 1000
kilomètres avec un de nos camions nous
faisons 800 km sur la voie le chemin de
fer et 200 km sur le sur la route donc
du jour au lendemain nous sommes obligés
de changer notre organisation pour ses
800 km de parcours ferroviaire
l'entreprise livre 75 caisses de
marchandises par jour l'équivalent d'un
immeuble de six étages
aussi ne peut-elle pas se permettre de
faire attendre ses clients pour pallier
les défaillances de la sncf et respecter
les délais elle a dû prendre des mesures
d'urgences embauche de personnel
intérimaire location de camions
supplémentaires et sous traitance de
certaines livraisons à des concurrents
ou on est assez perturbé leur faire dans
les bureaux ensuite et l'effervescence
tout particulièrement au service
exploitation qui prend les commandes et
assure le suivi les chargements toutes
les forces sont mobilisés très bientôt
d'habitude les forcément les chauffeurs
doivent prendre soin pour organiser
différemment cette nouvelle organisation
revient cher quarante à cinquante mille
francs par jour
un surcoût que cette pme ne pourra sans
doute pas assumer trop longtemps le
mouvement de grève dans les universités
est passée au second plan ces derniers
jours pour cause de grève à la sncf mais
à 48 heures de la grande manifestation
nationale de jeudi
on peut dire que la mobilisation reste
importante en province en revanche à
paris les prémices d'une négociation
sont bien réels marie pierre farkas
françois garnier qui musique feux de
joie sur la place du capitole à toulouse
les étudiants exportent leurs
revendications en centre-ville juste
pour prouver que le mouvement n'a pas
faibli
après tout la fac et là ce matin pour
accueillir le médiateur du ministère
gérardin d'air en fin de journée dresse
un premier constat à l'amiable à paris
des présidents d'université propose une
plate forme de revendications 1200
postes d'enseignants 370 millions de
francs peut-être de quoi négocier
c'est une base de travail qui nous
paraît intéressante moi je ne sais pas
si le chiffrage qui est annoncé le bon
en tout cas l'université ne s'en sortira
pas à la crise universitaire ne sera pas
résolue sans qu'on y met les moyens
crois qu'il est bon de noter
qu'aujourd'hui toute la communauté
universitaire les étudiants et
personnels les enseignants et les
présidents d'université vont globalement
dans le même sens
mais maintenant la balle est dans le
camp du gouvernement jusqu'à preuve du
contraire monsieur bio pour l'instant on
est resté à 200 millions france qui ne
suit pas ce qui ne suffit pas les
présidents des universités ne sont les
porte-parole de personnes il les expose
le point de vue qui est le leur il ne se
situe pas un intermédiaire entre le
gouvernement et les étudiants encore une
fois il reflète la situation telle qu'il
a ressenti et il essaie d'exposer les
mesures qui à leur sens pourrait
permettre de sortir de la crise
philippe ardent admet qu'on aurait pu
éviter la crise il sait que les
étudiants seront jeudi dans la rue il
espère simplement que dès vendredi le
ministre acceptera de les recevoir pour
une fois bernard tapie ne fait pas la
une de l'actualité aujourd'hui il a tout
de même été condamné ce matin en appel
dans l' affaire de corruption du match
valenciennes marseille deux ans de
prison dont huit mois ferme
il s'est aussitôt pourvue en cassation
condamnation également du maire de
béthune monsieur jacques mellick un an
de prison avec sursis pour subornation
de témoin dominique verdeilhan bernie
mairie bernard tapie a une manie ils
regardent souvent ça montre signe
évident que cet homme pressé sait aussi
que son temps de liberté lui est compté
l'idée d'aller en prison de terry ficher
la trouille avait il dit avant son
procès à sa sortie de l'audience
visage du député s'est durcie d'api
accuse le coup certes les juges de douai
se sont montrés moins sévères que ceux
de valenciennes
mais bernard tapie a perdu le deuxième
match son nouveau système de défense n'a
pas atteint son but chacun de nous après
sur un représente huit mois de prison
ferme par rapport par rapport à ce qui
était reproché c'est à dire deux cent
cinquante mille francs qui ont été
données je confirme et je continue à
dire à mon insu pour un match de
football à l'écart jean pierre bernès
savoure ce petit moment de victoire
d'abord parce que les magistrats ne le
renvoie pas en prison ensuite parce que
c'est sa version et non celle de tapis
qui a convaincu les juges
c est juste
les vraies responsabilités voilà à douai
bernard tapie avait émis un voeu être
jugé comme un citoyen ordinaire
seulement c'est bien son statut de
député qui va lui permettre d'échapper
provisoirement à la prison son immunité
parlementaire va effectivement le
protéger jusqu'à ce que sa condamnation
soit rendue définitive par la cour de
cassation dans le dossier om veut à
bernard tapie a donc encore un an devant
lui seulement entre-temps d'autres
procès l'attendent
bernard tapie a donc raison de regarder
sa montre manifestation cet après midi
sur l'esplanade du trocadéro à paris le
comité de soutien à la jeune sarah
condamné dans les émirats arabes unis
pour avoir assassiné son employeur qu'il
avait violé entend bien obtenir la grâce
de la jeune fille qui a été condamné
vous le savez à un an de prison et 100
coups de canne l'actualité
internationale vingt mille hommes sur le
terrain le président américain bill
clinton a prononcé un discours télévisé
pour expliquer aux américains qu'il
était nécessaire que les gi's débarque
en bosnie pour garantir les récents
accords de paix philippe gassot c'est
avec solennité que le président s'est
adressé à l'amérique pour lui demander
son appui afin de défendre la paix en
bosnie il a expliqué que les vingt mille
soldats dépéchés sur place aurait une
mission bien défini et limité dans le
temps
ils seraient placés sous commandement
américain et que la mission comporterait
des risques
il a su trouver les mots pour convaincre
si l'on en croit la presse
l'amérique ne peut pas et ne veut pas
être gardienne de la fusion nous ne
pouvons pas arrêter toutes les guerres
tout le temps mais nous pouvons arrêter
quelques-unes se ne pouvons pas sauver
toutes les femmes et tous les enfants
mais nous pouvons sauver beaucoup
nous ne pouvons pas tout faire mais nous
devons faire ce que nous pouvons
ce discours a troublé l'opposition son
leader a même salué la performance
je crois que le président a fait les
premiers pas dans la bonne direction
nous allons voir maintenant ce qu'en
pensent les amériques
le président clinton a insisté hier soir
sur la capacité de ses troupes à
contrôler la situation à garder la paix
sur le terrain
il est vrai que depuis des mois les
américains s'entraînent que ce soit en
allemagne où ici sur le sol américain en
compagnie de croates deux russes anglais
ou autre ils se sont familiarisés à
lutter contre le terrorisme
la bataille de rue les mouvements de
paul et même la protection des
populations civiles
pour le président clinton ils sont prêts
le président américain est aussi le chef
suprême des armées ssa ne l'empêchent
pas de pouvoir envoyer des troupes sur
certains théâtres d'opérations sans le
consulter
comme ce fut le cas pendant la guerre du
golfe le président américain souhaite le
soutien le plus large possible des
représentants du peuple et de la nation
américaine tout entière ce qui le
mériterait sans doute pas mal de
critiques et il ne faut pas oublier non
plus que c'est au congrès que se
tiennent les cordons de la bourse
bref encore fin de la conférence
internationale de barcelone réunissant
27 pays européens et du pourtour de la
méditerranée
la réunion aura été principalement
marqué par le premier contact entre
israéliens et syriens afin de mettre un
terme à l'état de guerre qui règne
encore entre les deux pays violence
également en algérie un général a été
abattu aujourd'hui par un groupe
terroriste et puis le leader serbe de
bosnie monsieur radovan karadic évident
évoque le sort des deux pilotes français
abattu au dessus de la bosnie en août
dernier j'ai quelques espoirs dit il
mais pas de preuves qu'ils sont bel et
bien vivant vous vous souvenez du film
de spielberg la liste de schindler cet
homme d'affaires allemand qui sauva
plusieurs milliers de juifs pendant la
dernière guerre mondiale en suisse
aujourd'hui on rend enfin hommage à un
policier mort dans l'indifférence totale
et qui en 1938 juste avant la guerre
fourni des centaines de faux papiers à
des juifs fuyant l'allemagne et
l'autriche cet homme paul winninger fut
même renvoyé de la police suisse en 1940
pour avoir enfreint la fameuse
neutralité du pays
olivier werner 1938 3000 réfugiés juifs
qui fuyaient l'allemagne nazie sont
passés par ici
protégé sur place par un commandant de
police suisse paul browning heures à
vienne ont cherché tous des solutions
pour fuir
on nous a dit un jour que dans cette
région on pouvait traverser à pied de
nuit paul browning heures officier de
police du canton de saint-gall
n'applique a pas les ordres de ses
supérieurs des ordres en contradiction
avec sa générosité naturelle et ce
policier donne le change dans ses
missions officiers un fonctionnaire
modèle pourtant running guerre citoyens
ordinaires
havel est bien compris une action
secrets extraordinaires dénoncé par la
gestapo qu'une guerre est destitué bay
condamnés en 1940 elle fortement
vous connaissez les risques mais il ne
pouvait pas agir autrement parce que
c'est noir bref je savais que je ne
trouvais pas les renvoyer
je ne devais pas les renvoyer face à des
gens qui fuyaient j'avais le devoir de
leur porter assistance de les garder ici
ruine est humilié groningen ne
retrouvera jamais d'emplois stables il
meurt dans l'indifférence générale
en 1972 à cinq reprises la famille et
les amis de groningen on tentait
d'obtenir sa réhabilitation cinq
tentatives cinq échecs
ce n'est que parce que les suisses ont
procédé cette année un vaste examen de
conscience sur leur attitude pendant la
deuxième guerre mondiale que groningen
va enfin connaître une réhabilitation
morale à titre posthume 55 ans après les
anglais avaient déjà commercialisé
l'année dernière les films vidéos de
surveillance des autoroutes
on y voyait des accidents en chaîne
aujourd'hui une cassette présente une
compilation des caméras de surveillance
installées dans tous les endroits
publics et cela provoque des réactions
qu à certaines scènes sont plutôt disant
imandt et eric lemasson
une attaque violente dans une bijouterie
comme si on y était une scène de vol
dans un magasin un hold up et bien
d'autres choses encore filmées par les
yeux discret des caméras de surveillance
voilà l'idée fracassante d'un producteur
britannique commercialisé pour 80 francs
seulement les extraits choisis des
vidéos normalement destiné aux services
de sécurité mais ce qui provoque le plus
de remous
c'est cela pris sur le fait c'est le
titre de la casse est exposé aux télés
voyeur des scènes plus intimes et divers
des habillages ce couple par exemple ne
se doutait pas que cédé à une pulsion
brutale dans un ascenseur l'exposerait à
la célébrité je être critiqué pour cette
cassette et pour la suivante
parce que ce que je fais est toujours
controversé en fait quand le débat légal
sera clos je suis sûr qu'on pourra
utiliser librement ses images le
réalisateur est sur la défensive car
c'est toute la classe politique
britannique qui s'est insurgé contre
l'utilisation commerciale des caméras
espions
un député demande une loi pour
l'interdire un autre demande la saisie
de la casse est inutile devant le tollé
le réalisateur lui-même la retire de la
vente mais au fait
tout en condamnant ces atteintes à la
vie privée combien d'entre nous aurait
avoué qu'ils avaient envie de voir la
suite
on célèbre en ce moment le 100e
anniversaire de la découverte des rayons
x qui ont permis vous savez le
développement de la radiographie
aujourd'hui est les rayons x ne sont
plus simplement utilisé dans le domaine
médical ils servent également pour
l'étude et la restauration des oeuvres
d'art et l'on découvre parfois des
choses inattendues reportage au
laboratoire de recherche des musées de
france au loup quand caudal annie claude
sicard si le parvis du louvre
le laboratoire de recherche des musées
de france ici au mot sculpte héros
soigne les oeuvres d'art certaines très
mal en point comme cette statue de
bernard palissy et comme à l'hôpital
cela commence souvent par une séance de
rayons x dans le cas précis avant de
restaurer il faut comprendre comment la
statue s'articuler sur son armature
métallique le même principe s'applique
aux tableaux de maître avec parfois des
découvertes inattendues comme pour ce
picasso qui datent de la jeunesse du
peintre elle arrivera si nous avons la
surprise de voir apparaître une autre
tableau à tableau que l'on a pu
identifier
c'est une femme à la capeline et il est
et il a été peint par la nièce de
flaubert c'est à dire bien des années
avant que piquet sont deux façons en
oeuvre qu'elle soit donc réutiliser
cette toile pour pour faire pour favre
ses oursins révélé aussi par les rayons
x et secrets de ce boss grecque trop
bien conservé en fait le vase a été
cassée au xixème siècle recoller avec
des agrafes et repeint à neuf
mais aujourd'hui on ne se contente plus
de la radioscopie ainsi avec cet
accélérateur de particules qui utilisent
d'autres propriétés des rayons x
on pénètre directement dans les objets
depuis
4 5 ans on utilise les rayons x
autrement on les utilise pour analyser
les éléments et cet accélérateur dont
vous voyez ici là des faisceaux le
faisceau extrait permet donc d'étudier
les oeuvres directement sans faire le
prélèvement d'échantillons
quelques secondes suffisent donc pour
savoir que ce chat égyptien est fait
d'un alliage de cuivre d'état
c'est-à-dire de bronze ou pour apprendre
que l'auteur anonyme de ce dessin du 15e
siècle italien n'a utilisé ni crayon ni
fusain mais une fine pointe de plomb le
nom de l'artiste lui restera inconnu
les rixes ne perce pas tous les mystères
mystère encore en connaîtra à la semaine
prochaine le nom du grand stade de
saint-denis le comité consultatif qui a
reçu plus de onze mille propositions de
noms est réunie en ce moment même un
combat feutrée il faut le dire oppose
ceux qui voudraient donner un nom bien
français à ce stade du genre antoine
blondin le célèbre chroniqueur sportif
et écrivain de gaulle miterrand platini
qui a d'ailleurs officiellement refusé
et puis ceux qui ont à exploiter
commercialement le stade et qui
préféreraient un an du genre coliseum où
elysées sommes plus facile à vendre à
l'étranger thierry clopeau alain points
bernard pivot en tête
ils sont 14 à plancher depuis 18 heures
au ministère des sports sur le nom de ce
fameux grand stone de ce côté-là devoir
de réserve oblige c'est motus et bouche
cousue
une chose est sûre ce ne sera pas michel
platini le nom du célèbre numéro 10 a
pourtant été plébiscité par les 12000
français qui ont participé à la
consultation populaire organisée par
france inter mais platini a décliné
s'estimant trop jeune pour donner son
patronyme à cet ouvrage nationale reste
trois autres noms aux hits parades
tout d'abord le boxeur marcel cerdan
jules rimet ensuite le créateur de la
coupe du monde et antoine blondin le
célèbre écrivain journaliste sportif un
des trois sera forcément retenue mais
pour guy drut qui prendra la décision
finale
le match n'est pas encore joué des
paramètres affective des paramètres
aussi de de marketing des paramètres de
représentativité il faut trouver un nom
qui représente vraiment à la fois la
volonté là le devenir de l'équipement ça
reste un équipement sportif
toutes ces choses là c'est tous ces
paramètres qui vont rentrer qui vont
rentrer en jeu et se laissent ils ont
entendu ce ne sera pas forcément un nom
propre de personnalités françaises qui
ne seraient pas connues
internationalement intérêts commerciaux
de marketing oblige un nom générique
pourrait être préféré notre contrainte
c'est d'essayer d'avoir un nom qui soit
générique qui soit un nom international
et qui puisse permettre d'être exporté
de représenter l'image de la france à
travers le monde et puisse être déclinée
à travers différents produits dérivés et
qu'il soit la fierté l'image de la
france l'élysée homme qui en fait la
corde du côté de certains membres du
jury et surtout du ministère le grand
stade cela sonnait pourtant bien on
s'était habitué décision finale lundi
prochain l'alliance décembre 95 à 22h30
donné pour un soir le rédacteur en chef
de la france en direct nous proposons de
choisir les hommes les femmes et les
événements qui ont marqué l'année 95 et
qui seront sous les feux de l'actualité
en 1996 pour voter c'est simple 36 15
codes france de la météo dans un instant
c'est nathalie rihouet 20h50 un
excellent film l'éveil avec robin
williams et robert de niro 23 heures ça
se discute jean luc delarue jusqu'où
peut aller l'amour des courses avec la
dernière apparition télévisée de feu
léon zitrone 0,35 journal de la nuit
philippe lefait 13 heures patrick chêne
demain et nous on se retrouve à 20
heures je vous souhaite une excellente
soirée sur la prochaine